these hands were once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
i got some new language for you last
time you guys learned shipping we're
back
yeah
now we're gonna talk bromance because
everyone thinks that you guys are the
best bromance like i heard the word
himba yes himbo last night and i learned
him not limbo
do it very well you do guileless very
well and it's beautiful so don't take it
as a nathan all right thank you i love
it i'm here to uh
you know laugh at
my own expense your ex and i ship all of
our expenses
new [ __ ]
well you're so let's be honest you can't
look like you do and do the things you
do and not have something like it's not
fair the rest of us mortals
some sort of problem yeah i got plenty
but what do you guys think makes a good
bromance because i know you guys have
men in your lives that you're very good
friends with so what do you think makes
a good dynamic for bromance
well you can't
crafted or cheated or kind of it's
actually exactly right it works or it
doesn't yeah like the same thing you
know
mates with people in high school and
primary school
not out of any orchestration or any like
these are the boxes you need to take
it's like somehow just by accident just
people get drawn together
it really is a lot of it's like can i
bear to hang out with this person yeah
for long periods and and when you can
and like yeah it's effortless
there's a lot of risk and
i don't know so many times you do you do
things you hand it off to someone else
and you go
there's a lot of trust and like there's
a there's a safety i feel working with
taika like i can experiment and do all
sorts of
wacky wrong choices and i know he's
going to take care of me in the air and
i feel the same thing about you you know
i like i know like
you'll be very open to doing ideas and
you know because it's it's easier to
like just to try it yeah rather than
like wow there's no way i'm gonna yeah
because there's some people as insane as
it is i'm i'm down i'm on board yes i
will say this i think a lot of people
when they find out about all of the
aspects of love and thunder are going to
be
so pleasantly surprised so i don't want
to spoil that for them but what would
you say is the most surprising aspect
about the love that we get to see in
this because you also told us this is
the loviest and i can confirm it
absolutely is there is love
popping off in every direction yeah one
of the
i don't want to say mystery one of the
things we wanted to concentrate on was
like
what love
means in the film you know like i think
people come in and there's this yes
there's this idea of love with the
classic romance that's now that we're
creating that you can see on the poster
um but there are also other forms of
love and you know and it's and what the
title is i think is like one of the most
satisfying things for me that's what it
actually means there's a beautiful
adolescent kind of
teenage years romance here which i think
is so cool i mean we were all still kids
right we all you know
learned that the uh sort of
tropes and so on of being adults and
that's how we should act but deep down
we are still we're children yeah we're
still high school kids like just trying
to be right i mean you both look like
you're
[Music]
when you meet someone yeah i'm done
trying to be mature i really love that i
love that so much i will have to say
this
the goats chris so legitimately i don't
think people are ready i know they're
not ready for the goats
but what were the goats like
i know that taika directs from under the
camera so were you the goat
oh
you thought i was i thought it was gym i
thought he'd voice the goats no i didn't
know so how do they do that on set when
you're like trying to get these oh
there's no one screaming on set like can
make room for the dialogue you know so
it's an entirely cg built character so
we're having to pretend the goat is
there there's no noise nothing in fact i
saw a few different edits where
the goats didn't really make noise and
now they made
what were they inspired by because i've
heard people say it was the internet
video i've heard people say it was a
hip-hop song like what it's a song i
can't remember what the song is it was
some song with that screaming it was
just like yes
and it was
i don't know what the hell it is it's
it's not that like you know what the fox
says thing but it felt like it was
seemed like it was a similar thing i
just want to be in your mind one day
where you think that is like yes that
goat from the random techno song is
what's going to make
this part of this one uh i have to talk
about christian bale because he's just
absolutely incredible in this and taika
you talked about just how he really sort
of changed what you guys did in the
villain role but i just have to ask you
with this one in particular he's almost
removed from some of the comedy of it
and he just goes to so many different
places how did you guys find that
balance because he goes into these very
comedic places right after you know the
motivation for him to be such a
villainous person you know we also had
ideas of pushing it further with
christian you know there was we were in
talks about doing a dance
sequence that uh you know
his character was like i'm winning and i
feel good and i wanted to feel like you
know like nick cage in the desert and um
and wild at heart you know just like
this
why
just like dancing by himself celebrating
and i thought if anything i'll shoot the
whole thing and i think it would be a
cool promo
you didn't shoot it though no it didn't
shoot it
i'm so like i don't know if we can be
friends cause you didn't give us i'm
upset that i wasn't involved in the
dance
i've acquired quite the catalyst he did
a dance
spider head
he did a dance
waterloo forever
oh yeah that didn't make it in either
yep on the on the boat i'm going back
it's like a solo
solo to waterloo
i do have to ask this because it seems
like disney keeps spinning off anything
anyway so why not give it to you i'm
just kidding now what would be a cork
spin-off and what would you do if we had
one because i'm like legitimately
thinking a cork spin-off
has a lot of potential
i don't know what would be a style of
korg spin-off i've never i mean where
would you want him to go if you were
going to let him explore on his own
where would you want him to be you don't
even have to get a plot i'm not going to
make you pitch but where would you want
to be he needs his best friend he needs
his new best friend
and this is it'd be weird i would be
weird it would be weird without i don't
want to see you on screen without me do
you like seeing it you know yeah yeah
yeah no
i only reason why i say that is it's
been two minutes since you've been in
something else disney been in something
else so i literally had to be like if
they give him a spin-off like this is a
lot he's coming for your gig man that
would be like korg would have so you can
have it and you can have it well
deserved
ah
i love it look into the eyes of the
people that you love
[Music]
not me
what just listening
[Music]
i have to talk a little bit about it
because we did an interview with them
and you weren't here and we talked to
tyka about his pitch to bring you back
and he said she invited me over her very
lovely house she gave me some water and
we talked about things and he was very
cool and cute about it but he definitely
said that that conversation was what you
know brought you back into the mcu so
anything that he said that day that you
look back on now you're like that's when
i knew i was gonna do it
i think just his um
his being the director of this was
enough i was so excited to get to work
with him that i think i would have said
yes to
anything he asked me to do you know he's
just so so creative and has is just like
an amazing generator of ideas non-stop
it's pretty it's pretty incredible to
get to witness well the one thing he
also said too um was that how much input
you had on what jane was able to do in
this and he said that you guys
definitely
had conversations about how you sculpted
her new version of it because you guys
got to play a lot more with where she is
in this because she becomes a superhero
so what did you want to see jane do
knowing how you'd played her through the
first three films what were the things
that you wanted to be able to explore in
this film i think that it was wonderful
to get to play both her human side and
her superhero side because i think that
there's this kind of like
misperception that a feminist character
has to be like a badass all the time and
is just like
tough and
strong and powerful and like kicks ass
and i think that
to see someone
you know sometimes be able to do that
and also sometimes
have
weaknesses or faults or you know
challenges is is more
what feels like to me to be human and
that feels more feminist to me that like
allowing
a woman to be all the things and um
uh because i don't know many peop humans
in life that can be
like always strong so it feels much more
relatable in that way and
um yeah someone that feels like a person
to me what's so interesting is they're
two very different characters but i feel
you and michelle rodriguez would have a
lot to talk about because when she came
back to the fast and furious i'm like
literally you're almost quoting exactly
what she said like when she told me she
was just like you can't just be that
girl all the time because i'm that girl
most the time but on this other girl the
other times too and that's what she said
brought her back so yeah i love you guys
are able to do that in this one uh i
will say this though you got to do
something that i'm sure you probably did
behind the scenes in the first store
because there's all those props mjolnirs
running around but you got to like pick
it up in costume knowing that it's
supposed to like jazz you up with all
the power of thor so what was it like
picking up the first time as mighty thor
like what was that moment it was
incredible to get to to have that power
and of course to have mjolnir do kind of
like
special things that are specific to
mighty thor felt really exciting and
lucky and um really came from from the
imagination of taika and of course jen
also our co-writer
and the thing i really loved about this
one too is like you see you in this
action moment and maybe some people
forgot but i started with the
professional and so i'm like no no this
is where she began ladies and gentlemen
she is returning home
and padme come on now let's keep it real
but returning to this action in this one
knowing you'd already worked in this
universe where you were so removed from
it you were literally the person being
saved a lot of the time to now being the
person saving how fun was it to really
play up the marvel action and get to do
all of the like toys and stunt work it
was really it was really fun and it
really gave me a renewed respect for
what chris has been doing for so long
because i got to make the earlier thor
movies but i wasn't really involved in
the stunts and the action i realized
like he's been doing all of this extra
work um that i hadn't gotten to do which
was really like it felt so lucky to get
to experience that and so fun and made
me really love love making these movies
um
but also was you know i realized he's
been doing like triple the hours that i
had been
it's a lot it's a lot more it's
different hours because i will say as a
woman in entertainment when you talked
about being in the makeup chair i really
do feel you on that one i'm like i could
have gotten a doctorate
it's just a lot of times too so true um
i also definitely want to talk to the
fact that you got to spend a little time
away from the mcu and it's almost like
if you graduate and you come back to
high school it's like oh look what
they're doing now
they've done like a whole host of other
things but if you could insert the jane
dr jane foster also mighty thor into any
of the other avenger movies that you
were not a part of is there anyone that
you'd want to like slip in because i
would go to wakanda no matter what yes
but i get it yes
no i would agree with that i mean i
think that um
it's really extraordinary now to see
what a variety of female superheroes
there are which is just so exciting that
you know young kids can choose
which
superhero they relate to
not because of their like demographic
like oh she's the girl yeah that's the
one i guess is me but that there's like
all these different personalities and
powers and weaknesses and you can figure
out which one you relate to as a human
and that seems pretty extraordinary to
be at that point in the in the universe
yeah i think we all i think we're this
at the age where you can remember like
well there's the girl in the team up so
i guess that's my person or like if
you're the black but there's one one
black person you know there's like the
power ranger effect as they like to say
so you're right mcu is like
completely changed the other thing will
that's changed a lot is thor and jane
like even just how they are together in
this movie not just as exes but as
people they are on vastly different
things but
what would you say
is an aspect of the thor jane
relationship that you got to explore in
this one that was fun and new because
they give you guys a very rom-com like
part of it i mean it's in the title love
and thunder i love that kind of like uh
flashback sequence i mean without
without again without spoiling um it was
so fun to kind of imagine what jane and
thor's relationship had been
you know with him being like a god and
her being on earth and what the
what the what that dynamic is like in a
very like
day-to-day reality is pretty
was a stroke of genius of tych as i
thought in terms of like yeah just very
funny oh i loved it so much and as a
rom-com fan i loved it that was like the
minute he said he was inspired by
harlequin romance and officer and
gentleman i was like
tickets bots or like i don't even need
to think about it anymore uh another
thing we did get to talk about in that
first interview is tessa talked about
y'all's friendship outside of work and
this is maybe one of the first times you
guys have to spend any significant time
on screen but what was it like because
you guys are front row
seats for probably one of the most
jaw-dropping and greatest moments in the
mcu
for two women so i will just say this
what was it like sitting next to a
little work bestie with some popcorn in
that moment
it was so fun i mean it was really like
the joy of my life to get to work with
tessa in this way um
we obviously got to make annihilation
together and then became really good
friends and spent a lot of time together
working on time's up too and so to get
to come on to this set that she also had
had the experience of ragnarok and so
kind of could like be like oh this is
how it goes this is like this is the
vibe this is what the
style is our scenes together are my
personal favorites in in the movie um i
just love um
yeah she's she also her character is
just like i'm ready for that film i just
want to see like the val king valkyrie
we've talked about this we came to the
determination of a travel show or
farming i'm into it i'm into it all of
it so
this is my vow
oh god she will die
that seems a bit dangerous
this ends here and
now
i have to start with this obviously
joining if i had to choose the two
franchises thor and batman are not two
bad ones to say i wanted to be a part of
but the two directors taika and chris
snowlin like comparing them and how
they're approached like what would you
say would be their biggest similarities
and differences similarities in both
being brilliant filmmakers differences
and entirely different but
i love both of their approaches i was
privileged enough to be a part of the
dark knight trilogy which people
consider to be the more realistic
approach you know heightened reality but
nevertheless a more realistic take and
then the uh more theatrical and comical
take uh that taika embraces with thor
ragnarok and now thor love and thunder
as well but what tycher also does
brilliantly is he has a wonderful
humor but then it's really surprising
how moving um this is as well he's a
very sincere man too and he really
brings the comedy and the tragedy out
yeah it's it's very shakespearean you
could tell that he was a playwright just
the way that he approaches these
characters and he had a great compliment
to play to you it's just how
the reception of your performance when
they first started screening it like how
people are resonating with it and i
really think
like what do you think makes such a
sympathetic villain and and how did you
try to bring that out because again you
gave me my biggest laughs but also
really moved me with your performance oh
thank you very much um and all of it is
an experiment you know and and and with
the right director you give them tons of
tons of choices and then they edit it
and and make the choice and direct your
character in certain ways that i'm not a
part of in that in that post uh process
i do hear people saying ah there's uh
sympathy look he's still a monster he's
still a butcher he certainly makes the
absolute wrong wrong wrong choice but
yes you do at least understand where
those wrong choices were born yeah and
tessa and chris both i did the first
interview that we did for thor which you
know is on our site right now and it was
before tickets we even went on sale and
they were just talking about all those
choices that you made on set they were
so like mesmerized within them but i i
mean i really have to say when did he
become a character for you because i
know you and tyka really discussed what
you wanted to bring to this character
and so when did he become real
uh well i mean look at first off
absolutely mesmerized by their
performances too you know these are some
very very talented actors that i was uh
lucky enough to get to join you know
with chris and tessa and natalie and all
and all the rest of them um
but really it actually comes down to
literally a day or two before we start
filming and then
as you film as well you discover things
you work it out you see what's right you
see what's wrong you've got to trust the
director in that in
being prepared to get it very very wrong
in order to get it very right as well
but with the makeup artists you know i
hadn't actually i'd only been able to
imagine what i might look like the body
language etc
but these superb magicians of special
effects makeup adam and carla and emily
who for four hours every single day we
created gore and they they are up there
on the screen just as much as i am after
you've sort of found the character and
and everything that you had to do with
him on script are you in any way looking
forward to i know like the marvel dc of
it like i feel like a lot of people are
going to be coming to you now with like
both sides of it and like trying to be
like all right so which one do you like
better are you going to try and keep it
keep it i would say low-key i i i'm kind
of blissfully ignorant of all of that i
i'm in this wonderful oblivious little
bubble
where i don't even know half the time
what's marvel and what is dc so that
that that keeps me uh innocent
[Music]
remember what i told you
you ever feel lost
ah tessa i just have to say i can't wait
for other people to see this movie i got
the pleasure to do it last night and
when we last spoke i talked to you about
the dynamic between you and natalie i
have seen it
it is amazing
but really talk about like you guys got
to have i think like a lot of fun sister
moments in this movie and what was it
like filming those together so fun
because natalie and i are like sisters
you know we we work together in the past
and then have done separate work around
community building and and equity and
parody inside of the industry together
and have just become friends over the
years and so to get to channel that into
this
dynamic was just really really special i
feel like you got a wealth of riches
because you got to have like girl bestie
moments on screen and then you also got
to punch like a god killer and fight
batman
i got to do so many things and then i
also like there's moments where i feel
like i'm like the the funny best friend
in a rom-com like i have a lot to do i
still have pathos i have my my best rock
friend you know um my cohort i got my my
kingdom yeah um i'm i'm i'm living large
and so talk about that though
particularly because you're right you're
bathed in riches as a king should be
right
and a queen king should be uh but talk
about the the whole dynamic with because
you guys go at it in the trailer like we
can see
y'all really fighting it so what was it
like because you know this is christian
bale this is like you're going having a
stunt session with batman so this is the
thing
i had had a similar experience on the
first ragnarok which was fighting
opposite someone who i like admire
greatly and is a hero um i'd never said
this to christian bell but i'm saying it
to you uh he's he's like a acting god
for me and then similarly in thor
ragnarok it was like cate blanchett and
both these people i was you know
fighting with so i'm so excited to have
a scene with them but i'm also like
please don't please don't actually like
hurt them you know
so there's this thing of like trying to
do baby emotion of like i want to get
you but also be like don't stab
christian because national treasure yeah
and national treasure don't stab keith
lunch i remember like having to come
behind her with the sword and like ah
um
uh so it's you know it's it's a really
exciting
moment for me viscerally but the the
sweet thing about christian was he's so
fierce and so fantastic but every time
they'd call kite you're like oh you're
right you're right you're right he was
like so concerned about me which was so
sweet he's just like a big love even
though he's terrifying and fantastic as
this villain he's just like the most
lovable um like shifts in and out of
character on a dime and and when he's
out of character he's just like
concerned about your well-being and so
sweet that is so sweet and you're right
he does go to a lot of places in this
role all of y'all do yeah and it's
interesting because for a movie that
doesn't have to delve as much into the
multiverse as like say the last marvel
yeah
it does make you start thinking of all
the different versions of yourselves
that we could maybe get to see is there
a version of valkyrie you'd like to see
that you haven't got to explore because
you're right you also got to play
an instant as i like to say steal your
person moment like let's just say that
like you got a very good like
put it on the trailer rom-com moment in
this movie girl
no actually
so yeah is there any aspects of her
you'd like to see in like a multiverse
setting that's so that's like the sober
valkyrie well no to be fair to be fair
she's she's pretty sober she's sober
adjacent in this she really has like one
or two drinks tops and that's after a
big battle she's she really is like on
her
she's on this straight and narrow and
and the truth is even her drinking now
is more celebratory it's not from a
place of like pain which which it was in
the first one and i and i think getting
to explore that dynamic is is is just
like a truthful
thing that that so much of what inspires
us is humans even the things that we
think like oh that person is so hard
working oftentimes it also comes from a
place of trauma we are like trying to
overcome the things that have cut us and
that makes us better or worse right um
and sometimes an equal measure so i
really appreciate that you get to do
that in the context of superhero movies
because i think
it resembles like what we know and
understand as humans i think a
multiverse that i am really fascinated
to explore with valkyrie and we do this
a tiny bit just in the suggestion of her
like for example wearing a phantom of
the opera sweatshirt it's just like her
doing things on earth that she likes to
do like i'd love to see valkyrie just
doing like a travel show you know girl
like there's a multiverse where she is
just like
taking a year off a sabbatical just to
travel around earth and and and then eat
different foods and things oh i love
that so much mine was i wanted to see
her be one of these like instagram
farmers like farming things and like
telling people about the earth but i
love this travel one even more wait a
minute like in it like a like a farmer
influencer yes like one of these people
that's like i'm let me show you how i
got these vine ripened tomatoes so i
could so see that because i followed
those a lot it's definitely not no yeah
i'd love to see her do that i'd also
this is my
personal multiverse heaven i'd love to
see her
do some goat
farming that's
yeah
just hang just working with a lot of
goats maybe she's making goat cheese yes
goat
what else do they make with goats they
can make cheese they can make goat milk
but just in general anything dairy with
goats and goats are actually a huge part
of farms because they can be like a mule
and a trash compactor like they're
literally like natural farming see i
just like them i just like goats for
goats i didn't even know that they're
that productive see this is what i mean
this is i get her on a goat farm get and
also just thereby get me involved with
more goats i do love that oh yeah you
with goats that's an instagram picture
uh i love that thor and valkyrie have
both grown throughout these tremendously
and and the fact that they're able to
have multi-film arcs is just incredible
yeah but what's even more interesting is
the thing you talk about is what they
teach each other yeah and what do you
think coming into this one or leaving
this when they've learned from each
other like what do you think valkyrie is
pulling from thor what do you think the
words pulling from valkyrie
i think something that um
valkyrie is learning from thor and
something that thor is learning in the
context of this movie
is that even if you have suffered
loss or you are afraid of suffering loss
the brave thing is to continue to open
your heart
and that's something that has been
really tough for valkyrie since she you
know suffered the loss of her sisters
and i think that something that
thor
can learn from valkyrie is really
sticking around she's been able to do
that even in the times of like oh you
know i don't love these meetings and i
don't i don't necessarily love um you
know the paperwork of being a king she's
she's sticking in there because she
loves her people and i think thor
a little bit as the prodigal son has had
the ability to just like pop off
whenever
you know his whim wherever his whim
takes him and i think he's learning like
actually what you need to do is stick
around and be accountable to the people
around you even when it's even when it's
tough and what i love about their
friendship is also like chris and i as
much as we like joke and love to give
each other crap we're like good friends
that have a lot to learn from each other
too and so it's very fun to get to make
these films throughout these years and
and get to really like like last night
at our premiere it was so cute to see
our parents our parents hung out like
for a lot of the night after until very
early in the morning chatting and it was
like the sweetest thing where i was like
and you know we talk in these films
about like being family and then you see
like our actual families together
talking for a long time and you're like
oh it's like not something we just say
it's a real true oh that just warms my
heart it warms my heart and then also my
dad's texting me today like still
talking about how cool chris's dad is
because they hadn't had a chance and
they like want to plan a surfing trip
i'm like this is really cool oh my god
the dad friendship
that's store five right there
yeah we're all in the family